i hear this often like well this is what
they do in norway that's what they do in
denmark mark
why can't we do that here the population
of
denmark is 5.8 million people that's
less than new york city right and if you
want to look at like the demographic
info on that
it's probably very very homogeneous
right so
very very difficult to compare now that
doesn't mean we shouldn't be
uh implementing the things that work
that we can do but just for context
having a homogeneous
population just makes it that much
easier to
push through a robust welfare system
though i will say i think this is
important thing to note
the tax systems in scandinavia are
actually far more regressive
than they are than than is what being
what is being advocated for by like a
burning and aoc
as then they tax the middle class very
heavily in order to pay for their social
programs and you have like the bernies
and aocs of the world
wanting to just sort of tax the super
wealthy which
is wonderful in theory but very hard to
pull off in practice
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to yang speaks on your
thursday
update this is your co-host zach raum
and we're back with the
wonderful and unique fireball that is
carly
riley welcome back my adjectives are
changing
they're going to change every week um
unique and fireball
depending on how the week before wind um
the so here's the deal and uh you're
getting familiar with this every
thursday
at least this summer as we start to ramp
up what we're going to
kind of um launch this fall we're going
to dive in on a topic
every week um both carly and myself and
talk about
what we're missing what you're missing
in the mainstream we're all missing
that's true it's collective so i'm
coming at you live from a bougie hotel
um i didn't coming at you very much not
live but not live
coming at you i'm in this if you look
watching the video i look um
a little ridiculous with a bed in the
background anyways best i got but
today's topic
is socialism and it's relevant
because of what we're seeing in the news
on cuba and carly and i were diving in
like let's do an
episode on cuba and we're like the
reason this is complicated is because
we're talking about the term socialism
and frankly both sides aren't very clear
on what they mean by the term
um or and as an average listener you're
like i'm not really sure
what we're talking about and why people
are digging in on the right and left
um so let me see if i get this right
before we dive in
what we're seeing from the republicans
right in the left we're seeing the right
is right is saying kind of what they've
always been saying that socialism is the
root of all evil they're the boogeyman
in some ways keep the status quo but
they're like communism socialism
terrible
stay away and the democrats have been
now making this argument that capitalism
is bad and that the socialist
countries have gotten this right call it
denmark finland sweden and we're all
kind of confused but are they actually
socialist over there or not
i think it's not clear that those
countries are socialist in fact i'll
make the argument here that they're very
clearly not socialist
um it's not that i think that bernie
sanders thinks he's confused about that
but uh i think i think that's what's
muddied the water is you have had some
really prominent politicians recently
over the last x number of years talking
about socialism and
saying they mean things that don't
really mean socialism correct
uh so we'll talk about it and that's and
so what and so in cuba right now
um which we will dive into and give you
guys some more info on it but basically
we're seeing
the people of cuba are
standing up um creating massive protests
in the country
um against its communist government or
socialist government depending on
what we'll define it here um the left is
saying
uh oh the right is saying support the
people because communism is evil and the
left is now saying we stand with the
people of cuba but the us
is at fault for this not the communist
system so we'll talk about it but it's
reignited this fight
i think the democrats are being really
careful not to comment on communism at
all
like they're not saying it's not the
fault of the communist system they're
just
sort of sidestepping that all together
by saying hey we stand with the the
cuban people
and also by the way we should end this
embargo which by the way
i agree with um having now dug into this
like this embargo
you know it's been in place in some form
or another for 80 years and hasn't
changed anything
i do think at this point the obama pivot
that he made
which was sort of a different approach
than other governments that
other presidents had made in the past
was probably right but maybe we dive
into that a little bit more
let's dive into this because i think um
we're we're being fed this kind of false
narrative and my goal nothing like
somebody in a bougie hotel
talking about socialism that's true uh
here we are
nothing says i'm a capitalist like
so you're about let's let's so that's
the purpose of this episode i want you
all to listen and understand when people
are using the term socialism and
throwing it out there what they actually
mean what they think they mean
and help you decide where you stand in
terms of what you're telling your kids
telling your friends and what you vote
for
up and down the ballot um and where you
stand um in this
nonsense narrative so carly let's start
almost over the basics and i think
you're
um in some way you've been a um
like a warren buffett fan since you were
a small child um so i think you're but i
think you're relatively qualified to
give us like a lay of the land on
what socialism is and then how these um
both our democrats and republicans are
defining it
sure uh so like traditionally speaking
and if you
look in the dictionary for like a
definition of socialism
it's when the means of production the
profits from a system
are owned by a collective so that could
mean
the workers of a company obviously in
most cases it ended up meaning
government in some capacity right in
practice using government right yeah
in practice it often ends up being
government but the idea is that
profits and the means of production are
publicly owned as opposed to privately
owned
so it's about if you nationalize certain
industries right that's why we talk
about socialized medicine
because you if you're if you're
nationalizing healthcare
that's socializing healthcare um and
like a good example there was a pizza
shop recently
that decided to turn over all the
profits from the pizza shop to the
workers of the pizza shop
and so of course suddenly they started
making these workers were making like 78
dollars an hour
and you had all these like leftists on
twitter etc heralding this as an example
of the kind of world they want to see
where the profits instead of accruing to
the owners of the pizza shop
it becomes like this collective where
the profits accrue to everyone who works
within the pizza shop
so that would be another example of like
a socialist system
um and then when you talk about like
what the right and the left mean by it
i think the right actually kind of means
that
right like they're looking at the ussr
they're looking at
china though we'll i think china is an
interesting case because china is really
quite capitalist at this point
yeah at least but historically
historically speaking and then they're
looking at cuba
um they're looking at these kinds of
countries that have
most industries heavily nationalized in
cuba right now
88 of the people in cuba are employed by
the government like
everything is is essentially
nationalized um
and they're looking at all of the the
worse examples right they're looking at
the ussr and the mass famines there
they're looking at the mass famines that
happened in china under
you know mao and communism and so
that's their focus or you know and
they're using that
honestly to galvanize latin american
votes like that's what you saw in miami
you know in this past election cycle was
with these folks a lot of people who'd
come from cuba and they're
fear-mongering saying hey
the democrats are socialists they're
gonna turn the united states into cuba
the place you fled et cetera et cetera
venezuela you get
hurt gets mentioned a lot though again
there's questions about really is
venezuela actually social a socialist
country and you said this earlier carly
is that
socialism and communism defined at least
a traditional definition that you're
talking about
it doesn't really exist anymore except
for
cuba and probably north korea korea well
this is what's so interesting so those
are not players in the global economic
stage
i mean they're two of the most
dysfunctional countries yeah in many
ways in the world i mean i mean cuba
the left does like to hold up that cuba
has a really actually strong health care
system in some ways that's true i had a
friend who actually got a grant to study
in cuba and study their health care
system
it's a whole other thing like there are
elements of cuba that
they get very right um but they're also
as you can see basically protests a huge
mess
okay when you talk about the left how
the left defines socialism
this is where it gets a lot more
confusing because you have people like
aoc and bernie who have been
very adamant that when they talk about
socialism when they talk about being
democratic socialists
they're looking at countries like norway
and sweden
and finland i think aoc one time that
mentioned the uk
these countries that have these really
robust social safety nets
but like our free market economies and
and it
feels like aoc and bernie and a lot of
these folks rashida talib
have sort of co-opted the term socialism
to mean something quite different than
it
originally and historically has always
meant i mean
one like anecdote that i just found
incredibly amusing as i was digging into
all of this is
in 2015 uh in the lead up to the 2016
election bernie sanders obviously was on
the trail talking about democratic
socialism
he was trying to clarify what he meant
by that he's like you know i'm in norway
and then the prime minister of norway
comes and gives a talk at harvard
kennedy and was like i literally don't
know what he's talking about like
we're not a socialist country we're a
very free market economy
he's literally we have a free market
economy like we have a really robust
welfare system we like
we have high taking care of our poor
right yeah um
so that seems to be the critical
call it misunderstanding the way that
right now the right and left are talking
past each other
um and i do have to say it does feel
like it's been the left that has muddied
these waters
yes because it doesn't that this is what
i'm passionate about it doesn't fit the
left's narrative very well
in that if the rights like socialism is
bad and evil
the left is like when this happens they
naturally want to say well socialism is
good
um but the reality is at least in a
traditional definition of socialism and
communism
fact there's a fact not zack's opinions
that carl's opinion it has never worked
there's not one example of socialism and
that truth definition
actually working the closest ones that
we're talking about that it
appears that the left kind of picks and
choose what they want to talk about
and what they want to hold up as a good
example are your finlands and denmark
and sweden's and some of the
countries that have great social safety
nets which um and don't get wrong
those countries are doing great um
they're doing better than us um
by the numbers well and well let's talk
about when we say it has never worked i
think it's it's worth breaking that down
a little bit more for folks so we said
earlier like
there are very few countries left that
are actually socialist
so if you dig online if you look at sort
of experts talk about this
really there are five countries that are
get held up as sort of still being
socialist and they are cuba and north
korea
and then china vietnam and laos
but what's so interesting is china
vietnam and laos
all have pretty healthy private sectors
in their economy at this point
and vietnam in particular is interesting
especially as we're talking about cuba
because vietnam and cuba have a close
relationship uh
vietnam has been sort of an advisor to
cuba the
the ambassador to cuba has spoken very
publicly um
the ambassador to vietnam in cuba has
spoken publicly a lot
and one of the anecdotes that i believe
he actually brought up recently this
ambassador was
this ambassador in cuba said to build
socialism
with success it is necessary to develop
a market economy in an adequate and
correct way
so i already you sort of have this
contradiction where it sort of feels
like your china your vietnam your laos
are like holding on to the idea of
communism and socialism
in name but not really in practice and
of course they're very they are
they have a lot of central control there
there they do have much more state-owned
enterprises than the united states for
example but
he said he's coming out and saying you
need this private enterprise so
back x number of decades ago vietnam was
importing
most of their rice most of their
agriculture and they wanted to
stop being so dependent on other
countries so they
uh the communist party there did a study
on their agricultural sector
and they discovered that while
most of the land that was being farmed
was owned by the government
there was about five percent of the land
in total that
uh private farmers were allowed to own
and that five percent of land was
accounting for
half of the entire country's food
production essentially the
private when there was an incentive and
you felt like you owned it
the results of the food production were
way way better
so what did vietnam do they made all
agricultural land
privately owned they turned all of the
state-owned plots over to private
farmers
and they lifted like 20 million people
out of poverty that way because they
suddenly could
independently feed their entire country
so like when we talk about
socialism has not historically worked
this is what we're talking about the
countries that
even the countries that are still sort
of holding on to it have developed
really robust private markets
and that's when their people started
lifting out of poverty
[Music]
if you're like me you're always trying
to better yourself in some way but
sometimes you're
a little hesitant to sign up for like a
full like multi-week class or dive into
a full new topic
that might be a large waste of time and
particularly money
and i want to talk to you about
skillshare which is a sponsor of this
podcast because
it is a fun way and easy way to learn to
create without a massive commitment what
i love
so skillshare simply has
whether you're a dabbler a pro a
hobbyist or a master you're creative and
you can go online
and take these classes for all these
different types of skills so experience
real improvement with hands-on projects
and classes designed
for real life it's incredibly affordable
especially when it comes to these pricey
in-person classes and workshops i'm
talking about there's one on there right
now that i'm taking
it's by my one of my favorite authors
guy kawasaki wrote the book called the
art of the start
and it's basically how you turn your
ideas into high growth businesses it
cuts the noise out of entrepreneurship
how to start something yourself
it is awesome there's a ton of other
classes on there about building an etsy
shop or learning photography and a ton
of things you can do
right now so here's the deal explore
your creativity at skillshare.com
yang and get one month free
[Music]
what i want to dive into is the
socialist
wing of the democratic party because i
think
um and it's worth talking about because
one what's happening right now is
i love this cuba narrative which we'll
get into but joe biden
and co the left is saying we stand with
the cuban people
but we have issues with like the
historical uh
us embargoes and like we're not
necessarily putting the square blame on
the
socialist government of cuba because
there's a strong wing or at least a very
public vocal wing of the left
that is identifying with socialism and
the biggest one is the democratic
socialists
of america dsa um
and look they are fighting for i mean
carly you can define us pretty well but
they want to
it seems to me they want to take the
traditional definition of socialism and
evolve it
and there's a lot they have elected
candidates up now about you know aoc and
bernie is i don't think he's publicly a
dsa candidate but he's
been endorsed by them um and calls
himself a democratic socialist right
um and look they have a lot of policies
that
um many agree with that aren't
identifying as socials whether it's
medicare for all
or they organize really really well on a
grassroots level
they believe in really strong labor
unions they believe in the green new
deal
which uh we could probably do a whole
episode on green new deal but the spirit
of the green new deal i think is
generally um a good thing um
but they also have a lot of other
policies on their website that aren't
necessarily
fantastic for um
let's call it capitalism or the majority
of americans well forget that i mean
their platform explicitly calls for an
end to capitalism
i read their platform which you can find
on their website and to me it reads like
up and down socialism um you know i
they call for an end to capitalism they
call for nationalizing all sorts of
sectors again ironically
sectors that are not nationalized in the
scandinavian states like they want
the telecom sector nationalized like
sweden liberalized
and denationalized their telecom sector
back in the 80s like
there's this very interesting thing that
i've discovered as i've dug into this
which is like
aoc says she's a member of the
democratic socialist party
but then says what she means by
socialism is sweden
but then her party is describing
socialism allah cuba
not allah sweden and i i don't really
know how we reconcile these things i
don't know if this is just a marketing
ploy for lack of a better term on aoc's
front because it's
you need to have a term for what you are
and she's picked socialism
i don't know if it's that she likes the
majority of the dsa's policies but
maybe feels a little differently on some
of the nitty-gritty policies here i i
don't
really know the answer to that um
because the dsa does they talk about a
whole bunch of things there are a lot
about equity a lot about you know
feminism racial justice ending the
carceral system
they have all sorts of policies in that
wing of things
and that vein um some of which i i fully
agree with i would imagine you do as
well
um and and then they have the economic
policies and the economic pieces of
their platform which read to me
very much like traditional socialism and
they they do do this thing where they
have this line like
we want socialism without the
authoritarianism and it's
it feels a little bit like you know
having your case
i think that's a worthwhile question so
um because
we ran for president with andrew on the
concept of human-centered capitalism
which you could also argue as having
your cake and
queue like you know can you have a
capitalist society that
values human beings as their intrinsic
value as opposed to just dollars and
cents and like can we take the best
parts of capitalism
and and build it into something more
different and my question is
is there a same not that i agree with it
but is there a same
existence in the socialism world can you
evolve
take the good parts of socialism let's
call it a robust safety net and maybe
some more equity
well see robot safety net is not
socialism i i think this is where
but agree but it's part of their
platform right um yeah
i don't think so let me let me say why
human-centered capitalism what andrew
was advocating
still would involve hierarchies he's
just saying instead of putting
profits at the top instead of saying
profits rule everything
he would say hey we should start having
mental health rule everything we should
start having
you know concern about the climate rule
everything but you're inevitably still
going to have
powerful people and non-powerful like
power abhors a vacuum correct you're
going to have winners and losers but how
we're determining those winners and
losers
isn't hinging upon profits socialism
fundamentally is trying to
pretend in my view human nature doesn't
exist as it does it's trying to pretend
that we can suddenly
flatten everything eliminate hierarchies
eliminate winners and losers
eliminate power and everything can be
can exist within this like owned by the
workers
you know i i mean i guess you could
argue they're trying to put the workers
at the top but then nobody's gonna take
risks to start
businesses if they're not like they're
just they're trying to flatten things in
a way that to me
is completely unrealistic because power
abhors a vacuum
and so that's the difference to me is
saying right
great i mean like lovely wouldn't we all
love that the world was
beautiful and fair and you know we
wonder people we can hold hands
it'll be great and and the proof is in
the pudding like you had a socialist
country in vietnam
where people were starving and like mass
famine has been such a
a chronic problem in socialist societies
you have them
turn their food production to a private
free market system and suddenly the you
know the country
is is well fed like it it's and and
there's this very very strange thing
that happens
on the far left and you see it on
leftist twitter you know i've been i've
been tracking these
to genuinely try and understand and take
a sympathetic view i'm not just trying
to
you know entrench myself in an opinion i
already hold
but they're like it's so funny how
people are so excited to criticize
communism when you look at like how big
bad things are in capitalism
and it's like yeah you're right like
it's it's you know
it's it's a totally imperfect system but
we're saying when you wait it out
it's proving the other ones a hell of a
lot more effective
and every other socialism has collapsed
nearly
everywhere well one of the challenges i
have with your pizza analogy before you
share the profits with all the workers
um and generally speaking like i i
believe that like in in somewhat i think
workers should be paid more and that
sort of thing but
i hate that i think this but but the big
but frankly is
it it takes a lot of work and risk
and time and energy to start a pizzeria
you have to go you have to file a paper
or get the upfront the writ the capital
to build buy the ovens
buy the real estate and you have to hire
the people you have to put up with their
[ __ ] when they don't
show up for work and all some of the
chart and so yes if you're telling the
person hey you want to start part
pizzeria you have to do all this work
oh and then when you do when you get
there you don't get to reap the
financial wars you have to share it with
all the people that just got to show up
um what happens is you de-incentivize um
creating anything
you are asking people to subsume any
level of self-interest and that's just
not realistic
in the animal kingdom writ large this is
not like a human being
argue but the left and the left will
argue well you have there's a certain
amount of privilege to be able to take
all that risk and that sort of thing
which and in some instances i do very
much agree with
but that is a different that is a
problem you can actually solve within a
capitalist system
i believe and that's a problem we're
focused like opportunity and access and
um
better education down the list as
opposed to
solving it by having a socialist
equality of outcome situation
okay if you suck at eating vegetables
this product is for you this episode of
yank speaks is brought to you by
athletic greens it is the most
comprehensive daily nutritional beverage
i've ever tried
it's just wonderful green powder you
throw it in some water you throw it in
some almond milk you throw it in a
milkshake you throw it in a
milkshake probably less healthy but
throw it in a smoothie
blend up it tastes good and you get all
of the vegetables you were supposed to
eat during the day all at one time so
one scoop of athletic greens gives you
75 vitamins minerals and whole food
source ingredients like a multivitamin
multimineral probiotic green superfood
blend and more and they all work
together to fill nutritional gaps in
your diet increase your energy and focus
and aid with digestion plus it supports
your healthy immune system
without need to take lots of products i
have a friend that tastes like
15 vitamins a day which i think is
ridiculous athletic greens knocks that
out so
right now if you visit
athleticgreens.com yang you can join
health experts athletes and health
conscious go-getters all over the world
to make their daily commitment
to their health every day and we're
giving a free one-year supply of vitamin
d and five free travel packs travel
packs or clutch
with your first purchase if you visit
our link today so that's
athleticgreens.com
yang get your free year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs
today
[Music]
i'm curious your thoughts on this
movement in general because i think
on one hand they've got i think publicly
have recently said they've got 94 000
members in the dsa
um they as of in 2017
um or in 2013 their median age was 68
and in 2017 that mean age of members is
33. so it is dropped like young people
are swarming to this in a um
let's go young activists are swarming to
this in a relatively powerful way in the
sense that they now have
there are four elected members of
congress um who the dsa has helped put
over the finish line and get into office
that's alexandria ocasio-cortez rashida
talib
corey bush and jamal bowman um in
addition
there's a whole bunch of other city
council candidates
um nationwide i think it's 36 there's
five in pennsylvania there's seven in
new york
um they lead the they own the democratic
party in nevada
um in terms of leadership positions uh
and a mayor in buffalo
um india walton is a socialist who just
got won the primary there um
so what's the future of this well you
know
this feels to me like a classic example
of
i almost hesitate to say the extremes
getting elected
in like primary systems but
this is not a very big movement the
libertarian party has six hundred
thousand members
right it has six x the number of members
that
the dsa has so there's members of
congress right well this is what's
interesting there's this disconnect
between the number of like call it rank
and file official members of the dsa
and their representation
in congress and and look it's worth
saying again like
what aoc is talking about
i don't mind right like sweden norway i
mean i think there are other reasons
that it's it's silly to try and compare
us to them but
i don't have a problem with that but it
is interesting to me that there's this
disconnect between what she's saying she
wants and what her
party is saying their platform is that's
that's the piece that's odd about this
um so i think look i i think we're going
to continue to see
this movement appeal to people um i
think
as we have more probably natural
disasters a la covid a la disasters that
are brought on by
climate change people are only going to
get
increasingly sick of call it the way
things are
i also think many of the ways our system
is currently failing are the ways that
we are not capitalist
and and what i mean by that is like
corporate socialism like the way we bail
out these big companies
um and there's a lot of
there's a lot of socialism at the top
right now
in a way that i think makes people very
mad and they misidentify it as needing
more socialism as opposed to needing
proper capitalism at the top um and i
think all of this is gonna
to only fuel young people to be more
interested in this movement
um which
again it could go either way to me that
could be a great thing and we could just
navigate more into a medicare-for-all
system or it could be
a troubling thing and people could get
deeper into wanting
a socialist communist system that i
think is entirely unrealistic
and and kind of a bizarre thing to
advocate for what do you think i'll say
well look i'll just add quickly to your
point like um
talk about why it's different here and
then there we could probably do a whole
episode but
for example the reason we can't there's
i hear this often like well
is what they do in norway it's what they
do in denmark mark why can't we do that
here
the population of denmark is 5.8 million
people
that's less than new york city right and
if you want to look at like the
demographic info on that
it's probably very very homogenous right
so
very very difficult to compare now that
doesn't mean we shouldn't be
uh implementing the things that work
that we can do but just for context now
i think
sure and when we say it's all white
people i mean you know certainly there
are welfare programs that
haven't been pushed through there's a
lack of a robust welfare state here
certainly because of racism and because
you have a lot of white people
uh and white people in power frankly who
see welfare as like a wealth transfer
from
like hard-working white people to lazy
people of color like that there's a
really dark dark narrative
um and so having a homogenous population
just makes it that much easier
to push through a robust welfare system
though
i will say i think this is important
thing to note the tax
systems in scandinavia are actually far
more
regressive than they are than than is
what being
what is being advocated for by like a
burning and aoc as then they tax the
middle class very heavily
um in order to pay for their social
programs and you have like the bernie's
naocs of the world
wanting to just sort of tax the super
wealthy which
is wonderful in theory but very hard to
pull off in practice
except for norway yes they had they
tried a wealth tax and it repealed it so
we didn't try a wealth tax repealed it i
believe finland tried a wealth tax
repealed it that's obviously the big
elizabeth warren thing that again
sounds great in theory judge policies
based on their intentions
not based on their results look at this
jingle this is carly's jingle okay
um let's let's just watch cuba were you
gonna say cuba i was yeah i wanted to
talk about cuba
um and why this matters so
um just a little bit just to hammer out
some facts on what's going on in cuba
um the cuban people are protesting like
crazy um
the main the main things that have
um at least they've probably come to us
in terms of their why they're protesting
has been lack of food um lack of access
to coveted vaccines or just like
mishandling of covet in general
and then there's now been i think the
last final straw was these blackouts or
electricity shortages
um and they
have gotten more access to the internet
in recent years starting a little bit in
2014
and really accelerating 2018 um
historically we have always had an
embargo on cuba because we don't like
communism in the united states we don't
think it should exist
bad things happen um uh at least that's
been our stance on it so like since 1960
we've been
um putting embargo with trade we don't
allow trade to happen between cuba the
united states
besides food and medicine and that's
fluctuated in a number of different ways
obama eased this in 2014
which is why you saw more internet
access in cuba and a little more tourism
and trump came in and revoked it said
absolutely not
and biden hasn't touched it yet and this
is an important thing
to focus on for a minute the obama
easing it
because something that i've heard and
that makes a lot of sense to me
is you had this hope
start to to exist in cuba when obama
came in and eased the restrictions and
opened the way for tourism and
and opened their economy you know or
helped their economy in that way
and what's happened over the last year
and a half two years three years four
years five years whatever it's been
was like a walk back of that hope and
there is a very very there's a pattern
in like international affairs where
revolutions start when things start to
get a little better and then get worse
again
it's not it's no no it's it's yeah it's
not just
abject poverty or abject misery it's
when
people start to think things might get
better and then that gets pulled back
from them
that's when you start to see in many
ways what we're seeing which is for the
first time you have people in cuba
acknowledging that they're living under
a dictatorship for years they couldn't
even say that publicly
or they were too afraid to say that
publicly because it was taboo
and the other thing i want to point out
and then we can continue on with this
narrative is there's really three things
that have happened recently
you had trump
reimposing stricter sanctions embargoes
etc on the country
after obama you also have the collapse
of venezuela
and venezuela venezuela came in when we
when we were not giving them any
like trade specifically venezuela
provided them with
heavily subsidized oil so they were
reliant on heavily subsidized oil from
venezuela and
and that sort of collapsed
and then you have covet obviously hit so
these three factors sort of all hit it
once
on top of existing struggles frankly
because of communism because you have 88
of
the population working for the
government because you have essentially
planned economy because you don't have
private markets um and
that's been devastating yep and so i
love i'm
fascinated by this narrative because no
one's really talking about i don't think
we can actually say
for certain that this is a case but if
i'm a as a political strategist
this is where my head is at that obama
was like okay let's ease this up
let's help the cuban like the embargo
that the u.s has put on cuba is
hurting the people of cuba i mean like
it's less less money in the country
right um less
less everything um so
obama eases it trump puts it back
theoretically biden could quickly
say hey we're going back to what we did
with the obama era i mean he could do
that right
um however the big and we mentioned this
earlier in this podcast
is the big factor no one's been talking
about is the reason biden lost florida
is because of cuban americans that do
not like living in miami and dade county
that do not like the cuban government
and
are in miami because they want an escape
from that
and by the way if like you look at
numbers
in florida they thought duvall county
where jacksonville is
if they flip that blue they're going to
win because miami is always democratic
and miami did go democrat but it was
less it's usually like 80 20 i think it
was 60 40
damn republican um and that's massive
and if
there's i would say like if that keeps
shrinking there's no chance of winning
florida
for the dems realistically anytime soon
um so there's that piece of puzzle which
i think is fascinating in this narrative
and you've got biden coming out the
biden administration and his spokes
folks are coming out saying like
hey it's just that we're it's first
things first for us right now we're
focusing on covet recovery et cetera et
cetera so this is just not
a top priority for us right now that's
their talking point
for why they're not going back to
obama-era um
policies i think your take is is
obviously very interesting
and you know there's been arguments that
that's why trump did what he did
was to i mean he made the announcement
about renewed sanctions
on cuba in miami-dade county like to a
group of cuban americans
um while he's hammering how socialist
the democrats are
um so it's it's i mean it's a tragic
situation i don't like the embargo i
don't think it's helpful i think it is
just hurting the people of cuba i think
we have a better shot of getting cuba to
call it i would say modernize i'm sure
that'll piss people off but
by by building these bridges to cuba
um which was what obama was trying to do
um but there are
clearly all sorts of political
considerations that beyond just
the cuban people i um i have two
questions
that i think i'd like to wrap up this
this topic on um
one i want to talk about the future of
the party in general and then i want to
talk about um
how we as consumers of media
can like navigate this because that's
the goal of this so let's start with the
future of the party
do you we kind of touched on this a bit
um
do you i think the pressure
i guess i'll start my opinion on this i
think the pressure from the dsa type
candidates is going to increase not
decrease because it's
um it's good news fodder it's good
material right where black lives matter
is coming out and saying we support
um the people of cuba but we also blame
the us government for doing this
you have dsa saying something similar
you end up with like bernie
and co all like trying to thread this
needle but it keeps this like so
like we like socialism we don't like we
don't like all of it
um in the headlines and the republicans
will always keep adding fuel to this
fire because any time they hear the word
socialism they're like oh that's
yeah this is how they win elections this
is their like just hammer it all day
long baby
so i think i think the republicans will
continue in elections by this because i
think the average american doesn't like
socialism
um but do you think that starts to shift
or um like you think the dems start
getting more wins in here or like
the four hour candidates have happened
you might get to eight to ten in
congress but that they start to become
the exception not the rule where your
thoughts on where it codes
it depends on what they decide to focus
on if these candidates
keep their message about medicare for
all
and our current economic system is
unfair
without suggesting national yeah if they
keep it on
that i think you'll see a lot more
traction
i think where it gets muddied is you
have a lot of people who
who are in that vein also adopt a lot of
talking points
around identity race justice on that
stuff and whatever you think i mean
obviously
i'm actually in favor a lot of that but
i think the talking points around them
are often very unhelpful for winning
elections if you if you continue to see
that side of things really bleed into
the economic side of things i think
um i think you'll continue to have what
you have which is pockets of this
succeeding but in
by and large the country actually
reacting very much against it and going
the other direction
if you have candidates that are sticking
strictly to the economics of it which
was really burning in in 2016 that was
more
more his lane um i think you could see
more traction
in a way that i actually support um
how about you i think um
and this is probably probably answer my
second question too like how we should
consume this
um to me i think it's very the data is
very overwhelming
and historical anecdotes overwhelming
that socialism in the way is
traditionally defined
is bad it is a bad thing it's never
worked um
the way if you're if you're consuming me
the way that aoc and bernie and others
are talking about socialism they're not
they are using that term so that can be
scary but they're not fun like
theoretically they're not always talking
about
they're more talking about sweden in
norway denmark than they are talking
about
which means socializing certain
industries like healthcare
sidenote sweden for example has private
health insurance in addition to
public like i think the way
and i think what um all of us as
consumers need to try and understand
that um
when this term is thrown around on both
sides of the aisle there's different
definitions that people are using and
it's important to try to understand what
they mean
but i think the real future is i think
india walton who's the woman who just
won the
democratic primary in buffalo for mayor
beating a
at least two-term incumbent i don't i
love buffalo go bills uh
love you josh allen um but i don't i
don't live in buffalo i don't claim to
know enough about this race but i do
know
it appears that she ran her race not on
i'm a socialist
uh these but she but more on
power to the people and that people on
the ground or who closes these issues
can solve them
um and it was issue focused but from the
american
um like she's not calling for an end to
capitalism or in the free markets um but
more about
stopping people piling up at the bottom
there's populist version of this
and i think that's the lane um because
capitalism has a ton of benefits but
people will pile up at the bottom and
it's the government's job to kind of
figure this out and level the playing
field um in its own way
and great policies can do that um
but great policies that actually work
not ones that
frankly have been proven to keep failing
over and over um and that's what's scary
i think if we get more divided as people
start branding themselves in the
socialist lane
um it's just gonna ignite um
probably more fury on the opposite
direction from moderates not the far
right from people like hey
i i believe in a better health care
system but i don't like socialism so i'm
going to vote for the guy in the right
because or she other guy on the right
because
they're not talking about that dangerous
stuff and um so that's my fear going
forward but it's my hope for you guys
now to have an
idea of what socialism
is defined at generally how it's being
defined by the dsa how it's being
defined by our politicians and how it's
being defined by the right
and hopefully make some rational
decisions as you start consuming where
my mind goes i'm sure most of you are
going to have like all sorts of thoughts
on what we missed and how we
uh poorly defined it yeah i once met
talked about this on twitter and i got
you know all sorts of uh opinions so
we'll get some of that too but we
welcome it people are very passionate
about this and i don't love
that this stuff is being brought in in a
positive light because socialism has not
been good
well no no no no see i don't that's
where i disagree i mean i think that
totally of course again the way that
it's just that it's being redefined like
what bernie and aoc are talking about
or not i mean i was never a huge
bernie fan honestly like i like the dude
as a person fine but i wasn't
i think there is a lot of
unrealisticness in his vision
um they're not talking about traditional
socialism that's what's so
strange is they're just sort of
redefining the term to mean something
that's
much more palatable um and it's going
back to the fact that democrats aren't
good at branding things because if it's
not
this is this is a broader question that
i was going to ask is like sort of a
leaf
leave us with is why have they chosen to
describe this as socialism why have they
chosen to kind of call
redistribution socialism when that's not
really been a part of the traditional
definition
per se i mean i i guess there's sort of
a link there great question
and you play right in the republicans
hands um so anyway
that's our socialism debate if you want
to call it debate more of just a rundown
for all y'all
um thank you for tuning in hope you
learned something hope you can now spit
a couple facts at people
the next time someone brings this up in
your world um don't just use it on
twitter use it in real life pretty
please
we love you all thank you for tuning in
thank you yeah we'll be back on monday
we'll be back on next thursday do you
know you don't have to ask me when's the
end coming back wait it's monday he's
coming back monday come back
he's coming back i'll be here on
thursday he'll be here on monday do you
want him
tune in on monday yeah whatever yang
speaks without yang it's just king
speaks
we love you yang we love you guys take
care
[Music]
you